many celebrity couples were unable to
maintain
their love in lockdown garth brooks and
tricia gearwood
came out stronger than ever but i mean
are we really that surprised they're
kind of adorable
yeah speaking with guest host twitch on
fridays the ellen degeneres show
the power couple opened up about their
two-week quarantine after trisha tested
positive for coven 19 last month
she's doing great and i got to tell you
man i'm i'm not a guy that believes in
pyramids or stars lining up and stuff
but i do believe in the power of prayer
and i think the second that everybody
knew that um she was kind of uh
facing this thing here came all the
thoughts and all the prayers and it
worked and she's
she's more gorgeous than she's ever been
she seems to be 100 she's real
she got real at the end there during
fatigue she got real impatient
really kind of mean and sassy and i
thought well she's back there herself
we kind of used it to work on ourselves
because we were kind of by ourselves for
but you know two weeks almost three
weeks absolutely which is all which is i
mean uh listen it's a
if th these times are special we're
spending a lot of time together and and
y'all just also celebrated your 15th
wedding anniversary
so how has that has yeah we can cut for
that broadway
um how has you know spending time in
quarantine
uh been for y'all well you know i think
uh i think 99.9
of the people wouldn't have done what
what i do but i thought since we're here
and we ain't got nowhere to go let's
just attack some of the hardest things
over the 15 years that bugs one of us
right and it was like living in a little
house to which it was like you couldn't
go anywhere so you couldn't walk away
from the conversation
and uh i thought it was great i think we
uh
i think we came out on the other end
even closer and tighter than we were
when we went in
you know we spent basically this whole
year we've never been together we're
together most of the time but we you
know everybody's been home
right so yeah you don't you there's
nowhere to run and it's good it's you
know if you can if you can talk about
the hard stuff
it's good and we're in this for the long
haul so um you're stuck with me and i am
sassy again
i'm feeling good everything
okay she said i am sassy she's owning
that okay so andy's already giving a
shout out to garth brooks and his beard
he does look good with a beard i think
that's great um
garth um went to biden's inauguration
thought that was great
um and uh yeah just a lot of love for
those two lindsay's just saying
love uh sandra's saying wow i did not
realize that was garth what a cutie
honestly people are loving the beard
right now
um andy saying i haven't been married
but it sounds like they put in the work
yeah i mean
you you've been married for several
years i mean this has been an
interesting time for a lot of couples
who
a lot of the time spend a lot of time
apart
yeah maybe we should have like an e.t
canada live where sam and i are sitting
down and having those tough
conversations together
we'll just watch it live uh it tests
your relationship it really does uh you
find things that you
you didn't know you're annoyed by like
when sam's sitting next to me he's
eating and he i hear he's chewing and
just like it notes the crap
out of me and it's something i
discovered now
and it's the little things but uh you
know
it's it's amazing we haven't done that
we've never
tackled the tough situation
conversations and you're right you have
nowhere to run but that is an
interesting way it can go either way it
could go really well or really really
bad
uh but yes your relationships are of
course tested when you're at home and
you see each other almost
every single day and um but you know you
that you realize you are married you
know because we travel so much and he's
i'm like you know it's yeah we've been
together for what 24 5 years now and uh
you know i still love it we're we're
still great but
yeah that is hilarious that they
actually tackled it that's incredible i
wonder what is some of the hard
conversations
hmm i mean and it's tricky too like we
obviously focus on the celebrity and the
breakups and who
you know was able to survive this
pandemic but a lot of the time
celebrities
musicians they're on the road they're on
film sets for months and months
at a time this is the first time in all
like in a lot of people in their careers
we've interviewed a lot of celebrities
this is the first time in their entire
life
that they've been in one place for
months almost a year
so it is really fascinating to see you
know if you're with the right person the
right compatible person of course it's
not easy
i don't think anyone says it's not easy
with someone
um but yeah it is nice seeing couples
get really like my brother and his
girlfriend they've been together for
years they've gotten closer than ever
like it's so nice
it can go the other way i actually
watched i watched a video of a guy
who lives so they got separated while
they're in covid but she can't move out
yeah
so they they're separated but they still
live together and i just thought it's
the
funniest thing ever so they're going
through divorce
together in one apartment in a condo and
i just thought
this is the most i hope they get back
together i gotta catch up on this guy
but
i'm like it's so fascinating to see how
covet has brought
relationships together and some have
been separated from the experience but
uh but kudos to them i think their
relationship is gonna be so much more
stronger by
by just basing it's like therapy it's
great i know
i know and yeah and the fact that they
still get along they still like each
other i think that's so important you
can love someone but you still gotta
they like them like each other talk
about the importance right girls
all right